so you've got this huge push right now
from the liberal establishment and it's
it's a bigger push
than even than usual you've got the New
York Times blaming conservatives for
Balenciaga child pornography shoots
right that's pretty outrageous you've
got the Republicans advancing a radical
marriage law far to the left of Barack
Obama in 2011.
you've got you've got the World Health
Organization saying don't worry about
what actually causes any sorts of
diseases or epidemics just we just have
to change the name that's all that
really matters
and now
the cherry on top probably the most
ridiculous least believable part of all
of this
Don Lemon is insisting that CNN
has never been liberal press like he's
the he's the CEO of CNN he's your boss
now he's just he used to stand right
over there he's standing right over
there and hit the Applause sign right
forward to commercial basically all his
job was and now he's got a really hard
job which is which is running CNN the
word on the street is that you guys
aren't allowed to be liberal anymore is
that is that the case I don't think we
ever were liberal what yes I don't think
we've ever worked not me saying that
that's the people out there saying that
he's not letting you be liberal anymore
well I listen I think that I think what
Chris is
saying is that he wants Republicans
sensible Republicans he wants us to hold
people to account but he wants people to
come on and feel comfortable with coming
on and talking on on CNN and appearing
on CNN so if you invite someone in your
house you want to make them comfortable
but also but by the nature of what we do
we have to hold people to account and so
that doesn't necessarily mean that we're
going liberal or conservative or
whatever it just means that we are doing
what we do and that's good journalism
that is not true that has never been
true
forget even what Don Lemon said about
CNN I don't I don't think we're liberal
obviously that's not true obviously
that's lying in gaslighting but even the
broader point that Don Lemon is making
about journalism look we just hold
people to account okay we've got that's
part of our job that's what we do we
hold people to account we speak truth to
power
that is not true
CNN has never done that
listen we've just got to be objective
we're not right or left we're not
liberal or conservative that's what
journalists are we're not we're just
objective that is not true that has
never been true not just that's that's
not just the case with CNN that's the
case with all of Journalism the idea of
the objective journalist who speaks
truth to power is a complete fantasy
that has never existed in the history of
the world okay
journalism is when powerful interests
seek to get their message out
that's what journalism is and
occasionally it's when not so powerful
interests like individuals with an
agenda with a perspective on the world
try to get their message out too that
would be independent journalists or
alternative journalism or citizen
journalism
but it all has an agenda
journalism is always a mouthpiece for a
particular world view
there is no such thing as objective
journalism there can't be any such thing
as objective journalism because that
would imply that one can be neutral
about public affairs
while advancing a narrative about public
affairs it is not possible there is no
neutrality and it's not just that oh
well too bad we can't go back to the
good old days of the neutral Public
Square that has never existed that was
just made up and it was basically a
psyop by the liberal establishment after
World War II to to establish what what
we now call everyone calls the left and
the right the liberal consensus
then some conservatives came in and
poked around at that and broke it down a
little bit and exposed the lie and the
Sham that that was
so it was so offensive about this I mean
look maybe Don Lemon is just ignorant
could be and I don't want to ascribe to
malice that which is explained by
ignorance and stupidity
but I I don't think he's
stupid I think he's a relatively
intelligent guy
and he's been very malleable over the
years when CNN has wanted him to be a
little bit more moderate he's been more
moderate when CNN has wanted him to be
far left he's been far left so he
clearly
is able to adapt
but for for him to say
we journalists we speak truth power
we're objective
it's just such gaslighting that's not
what it is okay
and it nor should it be that people
should not just be blank automatons that
view everything equally people should
not put Good and Evil on the same on the
same level people should not put truth
and falsehood on the same level people
should not put Beauty and ugliness on
the same level no yeah you've got to
pick a side of course you have to have a
perspective if you articulate any view
of anything you were taking aside you're
you're having a perspective
and unfortunately I think it was
conservatives who who kind of bought the
myth maybe the Liberals believe their
own nonsense but conservatives bought
into it too there are many conservatives
who say oh you know I just kind of
missed the days of Walter Cronkite we
could all trust Walter Cronkite no we
couldn't the man was a leftist and a
member of the world world Federalist
Society the man lost the Vietnam War
okay give me a break all right oh yes
neutral Walter Cronkite he was very far
on the left oh we just used to have
neutrality
no we did not there is a little glimmer
of hope coming out of even America's
blue cities it seems like everything in
the blue cities is just going from bad
to worst to worse to worse all the way
down the slippery slope and you've seen
this in some of the crime statistics and
footage out of Philadelphia or Los
Angeles or Chicago or whatever
but if you look at New York right now
the Democrat mayor of New York Eric
Adams has you got to give credit where
credit's due
done something that actually will likely
improve the city
people with severe and untreated mental
illness who live out in the open on the
streets in our Subways in in danger and
in need
we see them every day
and our city workers are familiar with
their stories if severe mental illness
is causing someone to be unsheltered and
a danger to themselves we have a moral
obligation to help them get the
treatment and care they need we can no
longer deny the reality that untreated
psychosis can be a cruel and
all-consuming condition that often
requires involuntary intervention
supervise medical treatment and
long-term care
this is the right policy it could go
terribly wrong there are lots of Hazards
here but this is the right policy it is
not compassionate or just or
conservative to allow crazy people to
die in the street especially in cities
that get very cold in the winter now
what you're going to hear is I think a
legitimate concern which is hold on
we're giving the state power to just
grab you and put you in a place
involuntarily and start pumping you full
of drugs and and filling your head with
whatever they want to fill it with yes
that is a hazard makes us all think
especially people who are civil
libertarian so I don't know I don't want
to give the government that power that
that was one of the arguments that led
to the abolition of the insane asylums
in the first place in the middle of the
20th century
it hasn't worked out there are so many
crazy people who we allow to live in New
York now I don't think mayor Adams is
doing this necessarily because he's just
had a sort of moral turn of of heart or
something like that I think probably
he's looking around saying man New York
is going to pot no one wants to ride the
Subways no one wants to go outside
things are looking pretty bad out there
we got to do something about the
homeless but that was that was the
reaction that Rudy Giuliani had in the
90s and he really did clean up New York
and it is not only good for the citizens
of New York the ordinary functioning
citizens of New York it's good for the
crazy people too
now the ideal situation would be that
families are stronger that communities
are stronger that churches are stronger
and that they can take these people in
but that doesn't always work a lot of
crazy people on the street don't have
any family left anymore or they don't
want to accept help from the
organizations that are offering them
services and that are powerless if the
if the crazy people don't want to go
we need the power
to involuntarily
commit crazy people for their own good
for our good for the common good and
this does not mean that we're now just
like the left if we're going to use
government power to do whatever no it
depends on what you're using government
power for if you're using government
power for good things within their
proper limits in their proper place
that's good if you're using government
power for bad things that's bad okay but
it is childish and morally blind to say
well because government power can be
used for a bad thing we're not going to
use it at all that is what has led
conservatives to be a completely useless
force in American politics and it's
What's led to this social breakdown that
we are seeing all around us so it's kind
of weird to say it I guess a stopped
clock is right twice a day good job
mayor Adams this is the right thing and
conservatives should take note
foreign
[Music]